alcohol consumption in the u.s. is
changing data from last year shows that
overall consumption from point zero
eight percent beer was hardest-hit down
1.5 percent and growth and wine and
spirits load compared to the year before
the changes coincide with an emerging
market that some experts have called
mindful drinking alcohol products that
claim promotion of health and a
healthier lifestyle Don Dahler got the
lovely assignment looking at this I want
to hear a bowl about this diet morning
I'll tell you all about a good morning
Americans used to drink a lot more
alcohol in colonial times we averaged
seven gallons a year I guess they were
doing more than tea partying back then
but now we're down to about two gallons
each and the types they are a change in
to the trends of range from cocktails to
mass-produced beer to California wines
to single malt scotch to craft beers now
but for the future of alcohol some are
looking to the past it looks like a
brewery it smells like a brewery and
actually it is a brewery but this isn't
beer it's hard kombucha a high alcohol
version of an ancient fermented tea that
has exploded in popularity House
business can't make it off can't make it
no yeah really yeah
Adam Heiner is the co-founder of boot
craft one of several hard kombucha
breweries in Southern California that
have entered the better for you alcohol
market and are having a hard time
keeping up with demand his company is
already expanding when 20 new gleaming
stainless steel fermenting tanks with a
capacity of over a million gallons a
year do you think people are looking for
an alternative to traditional alcoholic
drinks people are wanting something
that's a little bit more refreshing it's
not weighing them down and something
with more interesting flavor profiles
Andrew Clark is Boots crafts brew master
and head of innovation he's responsible
for coming up with these one-of-a-kind
flavors is it Hidden Mist oh it's always
hitting this they pride themselves on
never-seen-before flavor combination
using only fresh pressed fruit herbs and
spices what do we have here we've got
the Apple I'm jasmine
that's good grape fruit hibiscus Heather
that's really good ginger lime rose ups
now you can smell the ginger we make
sure not to skimp on any ingredients
that's listed on the front Wow
I have never tasted anything like that
this one is turmeric tangerine ginger
turmeric tangerine ginger hard kombucha
is a part of this emerging trend of what
the industry has dubbed mindful drinking
arguably healthier alternatives to
traditional alcohol that includes the
hard Seltzer's ciders and kombucha
brands cropping up in bars liquor stores
and on grocery shelves this is a trend
it's not a fad
Danny burger is a senior VP of Nielsen
and tracks the alcohol industry Nielsen
is seeing more bigger companies either
again launching their own products or
acquiring other companies or investing
in companies that have hard kombucha z'
there's definitely runway for growth but
despite the potential growth or maybe
because of it many of these emerging
kombucha moguls are determined to run
their businesses differently ethically
they say insisting on using only natural
ingredients and maintaining quality so
you're onto something here they're the
people one and you're gonna try to stay
with the ethics that started this whole
thing yeah you can scale and stay with
ethics as long as you have the right
customer base Gregg Surya the founder of
June shine and the world's first hard
kombucha bar offers over a dozen flavors
on tap how big do you think this is
going to be trans aren't built overnight
but in the next five to ten years I
think we're going to see what some
people are calling functional alcohols I
think that that's gonna be a third of
this section when you walk into a beer
wall in any given store so if you don't
currently see hard kombucha where you
buy your beer wine or spirits Heiner
says you soon will five years in the
future I hope that we are
expanded throughout the country you
really think that's a possibility
definitely yeah you haven't been
drinking today not yet I don't think
that's a possible I think it's a
certainty so I'm there's something room
it's supposed to say here but Anthony
wanted to go straight to the test three
samples done you're my man so here's my
question yeah well you have a hangover
when you wake up in the morning you know
they say you won't the FDA says you
can't make that claim but but they do
say that this has a lot of water in it
if you hydrate when you're drinking
alcohol you know that you you have a
less of a chance of having a hangover
also it's all-natural ingredients there
are no sulfites like in wine so they
can't make the claim but I'm trying the
cucumber mojito and it's in between soda
and something else